Kevin Rudd was Australia's former prime
minister and well before that career he
was and is very much a cynologist a
specialist in China with a PhD on Xi
Jinping he is also author of the
avoidable war the dangers of
catastrophic conflict between the U.S
and XI jinping's China here's our
interview
we're very happy to have in the studio
Kevin Rudd Australia's prime minister
from 2007 to
2010. uh Mr Rudd the fact that you wrote
this book means you think there is
enough of a concern of a potential
conflict why is that
well I've been studying China itself and
U.S China relations for the last 35
years and I've been a diplomat in the
past I've been foreign minister prime
minister and dealt with China and the
U.S a lot
it's the first time I've become really
worried about the real Prospect of um
conflict between these two probably over
Taiwan and so the purpose of the book
is to say here are some suggestions
about how to avoid crisis conflict and
War by accident and here are some
thoughts about how to avoid war by
intent later on
um I wonder there's a number of books uh
Susan shirk just came out with one
um looking at trying to avoid a
potential conflict do you know if
there's an equivalent in China of uh
books where they talk about trying to
avoid conflict with the United States
and I ask this because I wonder whether
there's too much of an onus on the
United States or democracies to try to
prevent uh conflict with China
especially when we see Beijing being
more and more aggressive
the bottom line is the party the
Communist Party lays out the line that's
why we studied carefully the Congress
report of Xi Jinping at the 20th party
Congress it lays out the line there's
nothing in the line about avoiding
crisis conflict and War there's
everything in the line about the
inevitability of China's rise the
inevitability of you know Jonquil means
the great Renaissance of the Chinese
people code language for becoming the
preeminent Regional and Global Power by
mid-century the line is clear that China
must prepare for dangers in times of
peace and also prepare for the storm so
that's the script being delivered
internally so therefore in the rest of
the world obviously there's a
predisposition to seek to avoid war I'm
in that camp I think war is generally a
pretty bad thing if you've got it in
mind for history
but I think we're the intersection of
the interest between China and the U.S
lie is avoiding War by accident in the
near term and using deterrence to
prevent War uh in the long term so these
are the two as it was strands of the
argument outlined in that book
done what you understand that there are
Chinese counterparts thinking about this
as well
on the question of the avoidable war and
using exit ramps or guard rails or rules
of the road as I describe them in the
book to prevent accidental crisis
conflict escalation War yes there is a
constituency within Beijing certainly
alive within the think tanks which
service the central leadership I don't
believe that the Chinese side right now
have an interest in going to war there's
a reason for that it's because they're
they are concerned they might lose
although concerned that the financial
and economic penalty against China for
so doing would be too great
so therefore the challenge now is to
avoid this escalation crisis conflict
and War by accident for which there is a
constituency I think in both sides of
this relationship but for the long term
uh Xi Jinping if you look carefully at
the 20th party Congress report is saying
that National reunification is
inevitable he's also said earlier it has
to be achieved in effect by 2049
and one key phrase he uses in the work
report is the uh the wheels of History
are grinding forward towards the
inevitability of reunification
that's pretty intense language before we
delve further into that I do want to
talk about Australia of course any
potential conflict between the United
States and China would have a big impact
on your country what is your worry for
Australia in that instance
well no larger worry for Australia than
Germany for example or for any middle to
large economy in the world I think there
are two immediate consequences one the
United States would have an immediate
expectation of its allies to support the
United States under such a scenario
which had the Chinese taking military
action to take China by force the second
is whether or not countries militarily
participate or not in that action there
would be an expectation of the United
States for all allies and partners of
the US worldwide to roll out
comprehensive financial and economic
sanctions and I think the third
implication is that whatever happens
with a or b above you would plunge the
global economy into the deepest of
recessions probably a depression because
these are the world's two largest
economies like the combined financial
markets at the stage between these two
countries is five trillion dollars out
of 100 trillion dollar global economy
now there's a lot of bucks suddenly all
that grinds to an immediate hold trade
is stopped foreign direct investment
stops the rest of the world looks at it
and takes fright so throwing the global
economy into something close to a
depression will be the third consequence
for all economies European or Asian and
of course we've seen just how
devastating uh the impact on on dealing
with Russia which is a much smaller
economy and then China has been on the
world I want to talk about Xi Jinping
and the Congress but I want to go back
to your time as prime minister because I
think it really tells us how much things
have changed with China over the past
decade I was foreign correspondent in
China when you were prime minister and
some would say looking back at that time
with you but also with the Obama
Administration Miracles engagement with
China that leaders were relatively
sanguine
in hindsight is that an assessment that
you would agree with and and do you
think your views have changed the
strategy employed by ourselves at the
time and I know it because I wrote it
um and certainly by the Obama
administration because I knew Barack
very well and work with him closely on
U.S strategy and I also worked with
Chancellor Merkel
was not unconditional engagement with
China it was engagement plus hedge and
the engagement was fully
working with the Chinese on the global
as it were Commons Global governance
maximizing Mutual economic benefit
maximizing Mutual economic
responsibility working on common
challenges together and the expectation
was that the Chinese would move towards
inclusion into the existing rules-based
system minus democracy okay I don't
think that was ever a realistic
aspiration for anybody certainly not
mine I think what happened with the rise
of Xi Jinping is China's own Playbook
changed the the uh China of Xi Jinping
is radically different from the China of
hujintao of Zhang zamin and even Deng
Xiaoping don't take my word for it read
the 20th party Congress report it talks
about the shin today a new era and the
Lal Shaddai the old era was that 25 35
years of
Reform and opening so this is a brand
new China domestically and a more
assertive China internationally
has this surprised you was there a
moment where you realized that things
were not going in the direction that a
lot of people anticipated
I think there are two things which stand
out for me one on pure politics now if
you look carefully at XI jinping's
leaked speech on ideology and propaganda
in July of 2013. this is an undiluted No
Holds Barred uh knock them down knock
them down drag them out fight with
everything that the west and the United
States and the Democratic World holds to
be near and dear in terms of freedom and
the international order based on that
and when it was leaked it became very
plain that Xi Jinping was taking a
completely different course on the
International System and secondly the
reassertion of marxist Learners
Cardiology because his conclusion in
that speech was that the loss of the
centrality of marxist leninism was what
actually caused the decline of the
Communist Party the Soviet Union and the
collapse of the Soviet Union altogether
so that was a big one and after 2017 and
the 19th party Congress there was a
shift on economic ideology as well
now um it's almost a cottage industry in
the Foreign Affairs World in terms of
prognostications with China uh the
coming collapse of China and so on so
forth but she is facing headwinds with
the economy and so on and so forth so uh
what would be your prognostication with
China
well there was a debate at the moment
about whether we're now looking at Peak
China that is a China whose adjustment
to the dung Xiaoping economic model of
the last 35 years towards a new Xi
Jinping economic model with greater
emphasis on the party greater emphasis
on the state greater emphasis on
Industrial policy and planning and
common Prosperity that this in fact will
so radically slow China's growth rate
that it won't be growing at five or six
percent for the 20s and 30s it's more
likely to be growing at three or four or
two to three that makes a Quantum
difference if you're looking at the
cumulative impact of growth rates over
time
I think it's too early to tell whether a
Xi Jinping can recover the economic
model but the early signs from the 20th
party Congress report is that the
ideological
orientation back towards the party
estate and ideology that we saw in the
19th party Congress that has been if you
like intensified in this Congress report
so I'm not foreshadowing any policy you
turn back to the market so therefore
we're going to have a slower growth rate
natural growth rate for China they may
prop it up through high levels of State
investment that may continue to yield
activity through net exports but private
fixed capital investment private
consumption as well as private
residential construction I think are all
heading in a southerly direction yeah I
mean the economy is at the end of the
day the most basic thing and something
that the party is very very concerned
with now with this Congress it doesn't
look like it's um on the political front
though we're not seeing any relaxation
at all are we looks like he's doubling
down on more autocracy and so on and so
forth I think if you look carefully at
what the Congress report says it's quite
clear that the political and economic
line and frankly the foreign policy line
are being sustained we do not see a
radical change in any of those except
that on the economy
it is somewhat more Hardline
ideologically not on foreign policy
somewhat more alarmist in terms of
China's perception of its deteriorating
strategic environment Mr Kevin Rudd
thank you so much for joining us good to
be on Deutsche Villa